Samantha's in Idaho hi Samantha
how are you hi good how are you thank
you for taking my call sure what's up so
we are definitely very good Ellen taking
baby step too good and my husband has
been working pizza for over several
several months now and we have a plan to
pay off $150,000 worth of debt and the
next 18 months and with that it's it's
been really hard with the pizza because
my two-year-old cries for daddy she
pretty much the entire time he's gone so
we're wondering if we would be
conservative eyes gizelle intense if she
didn't do the pizza since we have such a
quick payoff and we pretty much cut
everything else out of our life okay
well it's completely up to you you have
one child right yes okay I think this is
harder on you than it is the
two-year-old yeah it's hard when she
cried like huge cries I kept my
two-year-old grandson all weekend while
my daughter took the two older ones to
Disney and and so I've had a
two-year-old my house for the past four
or five days they just cry he won his
money he won his mama okay but I'm not
emotionally damaged by the fact he won
his mama she's coming home it'll be all
right and he's not gonna need counseling
when he's 30 because she was gone for
four days it's gonna be okay he's a
resilient little twerp it'll make it and
Papa David can hold him and love him and
reading books and Mimi does and he'll be
okay
so this really not is not gonna affect
the child honestly now you're talking to
a crusty old grandpa okay but who's you
know I've raised three and then I'm died
and so we you know I didn't kill any of
them I almost did a couple times but
tried to but I think this is just
emotionally draining on you is a and
that's a valid reason to back off on the
number of nights but I don't know what
time your two-year-old goes to bed we
put that one to bed about 7:15 and
there's a lot of pizza to be delivered
after that so you can decide what you
want to do it's okay
or maybe you decide okay we're not doing
as many nights but I think you really
want to get up under this and assess
what is really important for your family
over the next five to ten years and
obviously we don't want to completely
miss out on a childhood obviously we
don't want to damage a child emotionally
obviously we don't want to drain your
emotional tank to the point you can't
breathe because all you're dealing with
is a crying two-year-old that'll drive
anybody nuts and so you know there's a
balance here of all this that he's got
to come in and support you support the
two-year-old and you guys have to hit
your financial goals and so you know we
had a four year old and a seven and a
nine
when I was working 16 hours a day seven
days a week starting this business and
none of them were permanently damaged by
that but when I was home I was home I
didn't turn on the television in the
back yard rolling around or wrestling on
the carpet or whatever you know or
chopping wood together whatever we were
doing playing behind the boat when I'm
home I'm home I wanted to sleep or
watching HBO reruns and so but when I
worked or worked to get things done and
Sharon you know took care of the
emotional needs of the homeplace during
that time so it's it's hard it's hard it
she'll tell you there's times during
that two or three a period of time she
felt like a single mom and that's kind
of how you feel right now
but that's a price we paid to get this
business to where we are now and to be
able to do the things I'll just tell you
looking back on it that our kids do not
if you interviewed any of our kids none
of them would tell you they felt like
that their father was a workaholic or
that they were shorted or that they
missed out he missed out on their
childhood or any of those kinds of
things because it just didn't happen
although I did work really hard and
worked a lot but so I think you're gonna
be okay but if you need a little time
off if you need you know you know if
it's just getting rough on you it's okay
to just say that out loud and take a
little bit of a break and or just slow
down you know maybe not five nights a
week maybe three nights a week I don't
care or maybe not at all I don't care
but probably not letting a whiny two
year
I'll dictate the future of the family
either matter of fact I know I'm not I
love them but I know I'm not gonna let
that they don't set the they don't set
the agenda I do so you do at your house
sorry
hey thank you for the call it's a good
discussion and I appreciate you mama
sorry yes sweetheart
merry Christmas to you honey